the big winners of this beef are the
baby jay-z and andre 3k i think honor 3k
oh yeah [ __ ] that song man i was
like why don't we talk about him as the
greatest rapper ever yeah because he
don't want it he don't got no singles he
don't want no single album not even
about time you just don't want it enough
you got to want to be the [ __ ] goat
and he don't want it and he moved away
from it like when he was ready to be in
the conversation he was like i'm not
doing rap anymore
he's still the best is that crazy he's
the best of the best he's the best
because he hasn't had the opportunity to
flop yeah yeah sure he's the best he's
doing everything he does what can he not
do yeah but it's just feature put out an
album yeah
the thing you have to do
one thing you have to do to be in the
conversation love below that's one album
one classic lauryn hill got one classic
solo she's not the girl she's not the
ghost
conversation i agree with you it's kind
of cool
top fifty top five he stopped listening
to the movie music in 95. so it's like
it's hard for him
it's kind of like looking at a
basketball court all the technical
skills like like one of those instagram
guys it's like amazing at like free
throws yeah
yeah and being like oh he's the best
basketball player ever it's like oh he's
really good like he had a thing but he
didn't you know go on in the league and
try to win it like yeah you know what i
mean
you're saying andre treats that yeah
because i think that he is i i agree
with you skill level and like what he
makes you feel like like yeah that's
where andre raps
like we were talking about this he
paints a picture like whatever he's
talking about i vividly see it like i
see him laying on grass and getting
itchy thinking about his mom everything
there's a perfect image i never think of
a single thing when when kanye's rapping
like i don't even want to think about
beasting off the reason i don't even
want to think about it but i
when i hear a beat i see the feeling of
it like i think that's what kanye's
ability is skills
but andre they say is unbelievable in
that regard and he can do the m m thing
too where you're looking at just a skill
and you're like holy [ __ ] this is
incredible yeah he tells the story he
paints the picture he can make him feel
whatever the [ __ ] he wants you but if
you have a whole year to write one verse
it's like yeah i mean i think he spent
the whole year on the verse i'm just
saying like he has a lot more time than
other rappers to come up with a verse
i'm pretty sure he has some bars that's
like oh this is a fire bar i can't wait
to use this
in five months he's like collecting yeah
yeah that's interesting he also doesn't
have to put out 20 songs like he's like
yeah no pressure five features this year
and i'm going to kill all of them i
guess all the time
right here it is
six songs the six best songs on
certified lover boy versus the six best
songs on donda condom down to win not
even close yeah
i'll do the chat right now
[ __ ] not even close
i think you get a problem once you raise
it above 10 then
yeah yeah yeah but if it's six six if
you just put out a small what are those
called not even a ep an ep
[Laughter]
um so in conclusion the yay kanye stuff
what are you thinking i mean uh what's
it called uh drake kanye stuff
well what about your comment should they
finally oh god yeah i mean like i put
that on instagram but like
it's such a shame that they're like
beefing beefing like it seems pretty
real now because
they together would make the greatest
album we were listening to watch the
throne right you had a guy who was an
absolute and is an absolute master at
rapping with a guy who's an absolute
master of producing and they came
together and they made arguably one of
the greatest albums ever creatively
incredible business genius like yeah and
rapping genius yeah yeah like i mean
like jay on there are spilling hey
somebody said j's just bar after bar and
you're feeling this [ __ ] and it's just
it's yeah he's great pushing each other
motivating each other yeah yeah and you
know he had to bring it like jay came
through and there was like a hunger you
know like it was like i don't know maybe
something about like a kanye beat where
you're like i can't [ __ ] this up i heard
that you had a whack beat and you're
like
i could throw i could spit some little
[ __ ] on there but when you have
something
as beautiful as like who gonna stop me
it's like i gotta i gotta bring this up
to this level yeah maybe we'll get
another watch to throw them because i
think i heard they put that album out
and a large part of it was drake was
coming and that's where they were like
oh we gotta do something watch the throw
on the throne as hours watch the throne
and i think they said that in some
interview one thing kanye said that
drake would i mean jay would never admit
that even if he felt it but if they got
beef again and jay and kanye are cool
again maybe they're like yo let's do
this again [ __ ] it i mean let's run it
back i want
i want the drake kanye album and i think
it starts with one song i hit up
charlemagne i was like man just text
these both these [ __ ] and just
see if you guys can you can get them do
one song together because it will be the
biggest song in hip-hop history it would
be the biggest and it'd be [ __ ] great
yeah and they'd have to obviously have
to reduce both their egos a little bit
to accomplish it but like you have a guy
who's a master at rapping you have a guy
who's a master at composition and
there's something about kanye where he
brings the [ __ ] best out of you like
he won't let you put out some [ __ ]
yeah because he ain't gonna rap so
somebody gotta rap over this beautiful
ass beat yeah this [ __ ] just
talking yeah dude moses walks
[Laughter]
but what do you think it takes to get
a drake
kanye song just start with one song
sadly i think it's time yeah and that's
jay and nas had a crazy beef and then
they collaborated and they don't noz
wasn't as big as either of them and they
don't fit as well as kanye and drake
would yeah but it just took so much time
yeah and then by the time it came out
we're all kind of like yeah i guess
i don't know because uh drake is more of
a businessman and i can see him like oh
this will blow if we do something
together just like he did something with
meek yeah i think like a year after
he'll reconnect with anybody yeah
he would do it tomorrow kanye's just a
little bit
you also have to be careful because like
you could go in you could start that
discussion with kanye and you guys could
make a hit song and it'd be phenomenal
and then two months later he might have
some sort of mental issue and then
release every text that you sent him
yeah you know like saying oh yeah you're
the greatest and you know drake will
probably butter him up i can imagine
drake buttering people up if he's going
to do business with him yeah so you have
to be on your p's and q's with kanye
because he might be in a situation where
he just can't control himself and i
think drake also said in the shop some
[ __ ] about how he went to wyoming and
then gave kanye everything and told him
his whole life and then kanye just
didn't put any of that [ __ ] out and then
story of adidon came out and he thinks
that's where uh
right that's right so i think he would
be like nah i'm not working with that
[ __ ] ever what do you think mark
yeah exactly that like is this someone i
can work with and be close to and be
vulnerable with because either you're
going to sacrifice vulnerability and
it's not going to be as good of a
product as it could be or you're going
to be vulnerable and then expose
yourself to him potentially outing all
your [ __ ] and like leaking stuff and
texts and whatever i was i was uh
i was talking to charlemagne about it
and um he said
they could both really use each other
because
drake's sound hasn't really evolved i
think that's like a knock on him right
but but i think the reason why it hasn't
evolved and i think charlemagne was
touched on this is like
when he brought in somebody new the
quentin miller kid immediately got
leaked that he was helping you know
write bars etc so i think he's kind of
scorned so he's like i can't let anybody
knew in the camp and new people inspire
you yeah new people will give a new flow
new people help you you know push the
envelope and at least do something
different but if you just got the same
people you're going to get the same
product right which is working he's
[ __ ] killing with it but that's going
to be the same sound when he collides
with future it's fire yeah they can't
miss y'all they really cannot they don't
miss it and it's just the energy's
perfect and you know what it is when
he's with future he got to come with
some dude [ __ ] a little bit yeah like
you got to bar up but it's got to be on
some like you get [ __ ] it's like
super [ __ ] boy [ __ ] like they they take
[ __ ] boy up to the next level so yeah
they're trying to like outdo each other
with the [ __ ] boy
yeah that's interesting and maybe that's
why drake does uh features
uh is so that he could do some [ __ ] for
dudes
like when he puts out the album is for
the lazy that's for the core but he does
features with people and he just goes
ham and the dudes are like nah that kind
of ghost yeah because that little wayne
and uh rick ross that song slaps
yeah i was that was when i was looking i
was like what's the hits i think jameel
brought that up in the group text but i
was like yeah that's going to go for
sure yeah yeah yeah but i forgot the
point that i was making uh
why he doesn't collaborate with kanye
while he hasn't evolved oh yeah yeah and
then kanye kanye's issue is
at least for me is that he doesn't
either he doesn't want to admit the
things about himself or he doesn't know
himself he's so kind of like lost right
he's trying to fighting for identity
nobody probably knows kanye better right
now
than drake
you